والى الخبر العاجل مراسل الجزيره يفيد
بحدوث انفجار صاروخ اسرائيلي قرب موكب
جنازه مقاتل من حزب الله في عيتا الشعب
سنعود الى تفاصيل هذا الخبر وهذه الصور
اذا هذه هي الصور
نستمع
انكرها قولا وسا
فاجر الفقه على الدرب
جهادا انكر الفقه خمولا
ووساده العلم على قلب
الشده انكر منها قبولا
ووساده انكر الفقه خمولا
ووساده علنا على
ده انكر منها قبولا
ووساده
فادا انكر الفقه خمولا
ووساده العلم على رب
الشده انكر منها قولا
وساده فجر الفقه على الدربي
هذا فجر الفقه على
البم على درب
الشهاده انكر الفقه خمولا
ووساده اذا انوه ونحن نشاهد هذا الفيديو
مراسم جزيره يفيد ب انفجار صاروخ اسرائيلي
قرب موكب جنازه مقاتل من حزب الله في
منطقه عيتا شعب